welcome back the real estate market is
tricky and las vegas real estate now the
sponsors of this next segment they are
here to help let's welcome back to the
show realtor harvey blankfeld welcome to
the show buddy good to see you hey great
to be back thanks for having me back and
you brought a mystery partner with you
today who do we got i
he's the vice president of equity title
and i asked rick a bunch of topics he'd
like to talk about on the program and he
chose how to choose the very best real
estate agent okay let's start there what
makes a real estate agent the best well
in my opinion i think knowledge is key
they have to be knowledgeable about the
market they also have to be
knowledgeable about the transactions um
as well as they need to have some
experience in the local market as well
as the market that the client wants to
purchase and or sell in can you give me
an example of of
of a good realtor in action
well you know i think part of it is i i
always say experience is important
because i have that yes i have some
experience how long have you been in
real estate uh 22 years now um so it's
it's been a while so i think that's
really important because we've seen the
market do different things and we can
anticipate what's going to happen next
to a certain extent and what rick's
talking about is he sees a lot of real
estate agents come through his office
all the time
the good and when he was making those
comments about the things that you like
about he you should think about
considering for choosing i was thinking
about that movie um uh groundhog day
with bill murray
mcdowell and he's asking andy mcdowell
he says to her hey can you tell me what
you want in a man and she could search
china i want a good sense of humor i
want to like pets and he's going me me
me and i'm thinking just he's saying
that yeah that's kind of how i feel
right now
what are some signs if we're out there
looking how can we find a good realtor i
mean there's so many out there how as if
me i'll get ready to sell my home how
can i find that good realtor well i
think asking the right questions the
realtors are most important okay so you
need to be able to know what those
questions are so some of them would be
are you a full-time agent are you in
this business 100 of the time or do you
have a side job
second is how long you've been doing
real estate and i go in a little bit
further than that i would say how many
transactions have you done in the last
six months how many of you done the last
three months have you done any
transactions in the area i'm looking
really important because real estate is
is definitely
very localized how often are the real
estate laws changing
well they change all the time every
session every two years up at uh up in
carson city they change the rules all
the time and the united
all the st so you have to be mindful of
those things in terms of disclosure in
terms of a variety of changes like
all the change we've had recently in
rentals it's been dramatic in terms of
the relation between landlords and
tenants as well where's the market going
rick and i talked about this whole time
on the radio show right i mean i think
we both agree that right now where the
market is kind of it's kind of
stabilized a little bit it's softened
from where it was it was going 150 miles
an hour now it's going it's calmed down
to more normal speed limit it's actually
fairly normal right now less activity
more inventory if you're a buyer out
there who hasn't been able to find
something it's there for you now there's
opportunities for buyers absolutely find
yourself a good realtor to help you with
the products
find yourself a great realtor that's the
way to do it rick thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it harvey thank
you for joining us as well it's great to
have you on the show and thank you again
to las vegas real estate now for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-203-1165 or visit
lvrealestatenow.com we'll be right back